and we are live welcome to the last bird
with Laura Cognito and Eve artists hot
by the campfire the final campfire for
2019 assuring in a new wave what is it
we ever sowed any firewood are we live
whoa another one man another one we
still doing this damn pocket started the
last one in mercury so it may as well be
still doing it when mercury came back
around we come on yo you just put it in
perspective
Osiris throw Cyrus what is a list is our
last episode we have to end we've come
full circle yeah like the perfect
paradox yo real quick um I listened to
what we were formerly flashpoint number
one oh my god you gotta listen so far
scroogie but it was good I was like we
had to hard any baby like we gonna fight
for this game damn it imagine the show
level at that point it's gotta mean it's
gonna be pretty high not I'm not broke
we did it for the love of the gate I was
passion this'n to the episode one man I
was I was like wow we're out here man we
we want to talk destiny because there's
nothing to talk about
it's like I have not gone back to look
at my first youtube video and it's
probably just as terrible you've got to
listen to flash point number one boy oh
boy
shout out the fort a shower did dizzy
that's what CSUN why did I have a three
minute before I played stream hey Bob
just gotta pay two pills more now he
need extra cheese on his waffle don't
know how it would it you know I don't
even like fees on my hamburgers though
that is true I'm no kind of insert him
we've covered this but what's been going
on man the world of destiny what have
you been doing like how's it been going
lot to talk about yeah it's been it's
been
pretty good season two dawn so far we
now are in the dawning so snow flings
are falling the tower has festive music
snow balls are out whoa and there's this
essence there's an oven there's some
baked goods going around so that stuff's
back nice thing is when I logged in and
I got a couple of those quests for those
sparrows it counted the baking I did
last year so like my fiftieth yes like
done I was like thank you thank you for
counting the previous things you've
shown a shame for be so nice so nice
mm-hmm
so yeah a little bit of baking but
mostly just they haven't even done all
of those pieces yet I've just been
collecting things and working on working
on my polarized fractal and grind and
the obelisks and making some videos and
made a long ass with the obelisks that
was so long
I'm glad the ones who have watched it
have because I was like this is gonna be
too long oh no no bro you I went
straight to you when he had those out
cuz I was like you know what there was
some parts of it the intricacies I
didn't understand and you went through
every category breaking it down strats
how to do it where to go what type of
place down times shout out to the time
stands you got a respected content
created up I'd love to I know my my
stuff gets long so I was like I gotta
put that in there it's like a 25 minute
nine some people just want to see the
boss fight and I like skip love it but
that's one thing I love about your video
is that even with dessert the simple
things back cuz you go straight to what
you want I was like okay I'm gonna go to
Mars thanks to easy for let me know
crucibles where I need to be and those
are my two favorite weapons I've been
rocking that obelisk so is that where
you settled in first is Mars mmm-hmm
definitely been more has been knocking I
mean besides wasting about two hours
trying to unlock beed easy yeah EDC
interaction it's a little it's a little
touch-and-go it's a it's reliable but it
is there Mitchy
it's so weird sometimes blog and go
straight to it's totally fine other
times it's like as soon as it hangs
you're like oh that's gonna be like 10
times I'll like I'll reload that one
like a couple times cuz it's pretty
quick then I'll go to the sludge and
drive over a couple times then I'll go
to
just freakin shut the game down and try
again yeah my dad that's the way with
season and a glitch weird glitches
that's the only thing I would say yeah a
little low damper on this one but
overall I know it's still early and we
got a lot to talk about but how are we
feeling about the dawn what are we we
are we have to one third was even there
yet you're not even at the 130 are you
like two more in our second week of 12
yeah we still it feels like we're longer
yes there's been the story stuffs been
going on we've got the sundial and got
the obelisk opened up we've had quite a
bit and then now we got the new dawning
activity which feels like it just jumped
straight into it though mm-hmm it's
jumped in quick
I mean overall like the ten dollars is
worth just the two story missions Oh
already already mm-hmm
those are really really good but I mean
I don't know I would find it hard for
somebody to justify complaining about
the value of this season for two cuz
I've enjoyed the story missions
immensely those have been so good even
though I'm left hanging right now a bit
of that but I mean the Sun Niles like
not the coolest activity but now like
the drops that you can get from this
thing as you start leveling up the
obelisks and the season pass that's a
whole like that's word we're not quite
menagerie but we're definitely knocking
on menagerie store for drop level of
roles the perks you can get then when
you get to season past 92 every one of
those guns at the end is gonna have two
perks instead of one to pick from so
your God roles gonna be even easier to
get to
what kind of get to that detail a little
bit more I mean the and there's new
little perks in there we'll discuss the
mods what's your hit or miss mm-hmm but
I mean overall there's again this is
where I mean shout out they got the game
award for live service and community or
not live service they got the community
one which again hats off to the
community team Gage and Scott and all
those guys over there
Cosmo villain I like that whole team
does an amazing job to bring what the
whole studio does somehow connect it
with what most of the community does and
while it's not always what we want
they definitely still keep in touch on
both sides and it's impressive what they
do so yeah absolutely thought about it
last time you know it's been tremendous
it's actually been tremendous just to
see and um yeah but see how guys
celebrate it in now we move on to this
next chapter and this whole transition
man of them as the independent Bungie
continuing on you know I would like it
I've been liking it man a lot lot going
on right now we got stuff to talk about
what are you talking about no oh my god
uh uh oh sorry
chat is distracting and definitely not
paying attention I think they jumped
into the wrong podcast so so first off
like I mean the Dominic's out this week
what are your thoughts about the snowy
village event that we've got going on
what a door and I've always biased I
like to donate
I've always liked a little snowball
stuff the effect wintery stuff huge
dawning Armour fan I think those are
some of the best sets in the energy
already this one's a little warlock
armor I did not buy the new one yet what
I actually did is I'm so happy that I
could purchase the old word that I've
missed out on all pcs although Simon yo
that was my fav I love that set that set
right did a warlock settings pristine so
I had to get that whole thing got my
ornaments unlocked ready to go do my
transmog for all my little outfits I'm
ready
that was the first thing I did I didn't
buy any like a motor ships anything like
that I just did that and then as far as
the arm far is that what else are of
course I brought by uh my module
currency because you know I gotta always
keep that up stocked
seriously so Brian how do you had to get
a couple of modules you know just in
case you know for sells that crap for
like planetary materials and glimmer
what are you doing
listen guys you never know never know
you could use this okay this is my
public service announcement to anybody
who listen to this let's go not buy the
upgrade module thing for bright dust
it's like you're spending gold to buy
bronze you're spending a rare currency
to buy something that's that not that
hard to come by I don't care if you have
60,000 of it cuz I do - I'm ordering em
that stuff it's still you could buy
every cosmetic in there and your money
will be better spent than buying those
upgrade modules so please that is my PSA
not to buy that stuff but what about
when you're in the field what about when
you in the field and you want to upgrade
something but you gotta go all the way
back to good ol Benji to tell you just
wanna swim a little bit
hey that's a loading screen that's a
blow
you're on PC like me you can't complain
about that I've got to an SSD and this
zero compress on loading screens sir bro
don't watch my pocket I test made this
available for guys like me what to
upgrade on the go this is just an
awesome resource but I think we should
celebrate it more here in the last one
that's what everyone besides Lord
cockney know this is a PSA please do not
buy that I can't you I don't know what
it's called because I haven't looked at
it whatever it is do you know by the
thing from ever verse that gets you
upgrade modules you are wasting your
money anyway let me put y'all on what to
buy y'all let me tell y'all what's the
name of it officially so y'all know what
to get the test is hot out here baby
[Music]
have you found it we found our
concentrate it matter Jim for a smooth
two hundred brightness you too can have
an upgrade module on the flag lane how
expensive that is bright dust is hard as
hell to come by your daily your
repeatable bounties get you ten bright
dust so that's 20 repeatable bounties
for one upgrade module that is hella not
worth it or one weekly value
listen
a matter spider well he has this wild
prices for his stuff don't get mad at my
tester she's providing me a service that
I mean she is my beat your ass off you
are wasting your money this is the way I
am smoking shell dissent but I
understand your flicks he said I'd do it
but keep flexing video I got a flex if
you got it you can do it baby
listen don't matter how million I still
wouldn't buy that stuff it's not about
the money it's not a practical purchase
but anyway other than that about what
the um I guess I I just bought the the
old suit I didn't buy the new one just
yet I'll see what I can do with that no
war ii thought you're my supervisor
exactly tell him a word to it you tell
him do not let him tell you how to spend
job right ducks alright
this is your bread does you do what you
want to do with it maybe maybe we're a
better way to spend your yeah here
everybody's bright that's financial
advisor today but anyhow um moving along
other than that I've been doing that um
definite get my easy-bake oven on a lot
of new recipes little disappointed that
um big I don't know if you saw they kind
of spoiled that we gotta give something
to a certain person and I'm like oh I
guess that's happening you're gonna say
it sounds like okay cool and they shot
the camera for things that glad I have
receipts for I please fraudulent
tendencies hey hey you bill I told you
about the pocket watch I told you about
that's not healthy man who's that we
gotta go past that but anyway so yeah
we're doing that and then aw yeah
obelisk Ryan and I gotta admit like he
off the rip I will say this we came into
season adorned knowing no raid no
dungeon
what is this gonna be $10 let's not get
crazy right expectation and check now I
know it's week 2 it's early but in two
weeks we've gotten to amazing story
missions like outstay arguably some of
the best story campaigns we've done and
that's today I'll be at least in the top
5 it's up there I would say those two
missions are so well done we got that um
then you know obviously we got the Sun
Dial activity and then we see at first
when I'll be honest when we did the Sun
down I was like okay it's cool but I'm
like maybe I might get bored of this
quick right but then watching your video
the obelisk and then linking your
árboles to the sundial right and all the
different planets and stuff like that
and then maximizing the role so now
becomes menagerie 2.0 and to be honest
the same 14 weapons and my opinion are
very impressive I am very much liking to
say especially linear I mean especially
the UM the grenade launcher that's
number one they're martyrs retribution
that way that is no I know for you
Titans we have a thermite but listen
this thing is effective crazy strats I'm
loving it for table 3 dawn blade and
then I'm just working on the raw I want
to get demolition demolition is on it
and use all shout to Monte Carlo
you got Monte Carlo get your melees back
and then you got demolition is getting
you can hey back use heat rising you
just staying in the air you napalm bomb
and ac-130 you vote crazy it is oh it's
beautiful with a beautiful or you do it
this is getting that heat rising thing
going but anyway so he got that you got
all the other arm Osiris's weapons
coming back that were really good like
Jack Queen King a lot of these really
good weapons that was stuck in destiny
1.0 weapon 1.0 what else did the mods
and stuff double oven air it's just been
a fun I can't believe I've been enjoying
playing without chasing power like my my
switch because the grind has got me
excited and and I think again it's early
but just and then unlocking the Ovilus
you still each time you put up a
resonance you get something so there's
another incentive
go around and build this up I gotta
build it up and I gotta admit the last
thing I'll say is that um I think this
is the first title I will go for I think
I want Savior I think I do one I've got
a shot the Forte he got to eat he did do
don't have any
no III I'm Coast about two up close to
the crucible one and the are miserable
come out real one first of all takes you
three seasons yeah unless you see Israel
I'm close to the crucible one and I'm
close to I'm very close to dredge I just
got to do it I got like I just don't you
know spend enough time in here but those
are the ones I consider like real ones
you know I'm saying kind of thing but
shout out to gaming Forte because he was
telling me one of the requirements for a
savior is to be to not die in the in the
UM during the run so I got to kind of
play cheesy but one man should remember
that oh yeah yeah but yeah I think
that's what it is man but where you at
over I know it's early with two weeks we
we still we still technically honeymoon
I get it
but are you on the mindset like you know
what I might get into this or you don't
know uh I mean for me I've enjoyed it
though I mean it's like it's been a lot
of playing the grind is different I mean
as we said the power level it doesn't
take long to get to 960 the pinnacle on
the other side that one's there for
those who want to rate I probably could
use the run the dungeon just been
grinding other stuff but I mean so those
will be there to do but it's like that's
not the priority it's been the obelisks
it's been unlocking those the artifact
and then of course they season pass as
things that are worth getting as well as
you rank that thing up too so you've got
a different feel of a grind I mean as we
are two weeks in you know where they're
still decent amount that's fresh and you
can't have wandering these down times
when you look out at the calendar of
like hey we just have an exotic quest
well what happens after that well we've
just got this and then we've got like a
month and then we get to other stuff
it's like when we get to things on the
calendar of like we've got our iron
banner next week we've got our third
boss we'll see those
don't have you got the legend difficulty
which we'll see is gonna be a little
more difficult and then we've got a
quest and then like three weeks we've
got another quest and then we've got
kind of last month but still we don't
know could be a little life could be a
community thing not sure
right now it feels like we got
everything a little more front-loaded
before the holidays so when it comes to
like January that's where I wonder where
if it's gonna hold because January is
gonna be like okay I've probably got the
obelisks mostly done that grinds done
I've seen these do I like him or not I'm
gonna be starting to get a crapload of
drops for weapons and rolls and things
like every sundial runs gonna be like
four drops plus two and the end when you
get to the season pass so I mean if you
get to the middle of January and you've
got two things on the calendar for like
a month and a half then you're like
[Music]
Wayne seem oh yeah it's like I'm not
gonna just like pluck a number a great
on this thing two weeks in it started
well I like the offers that they've got
the obelisk has been a different kind
these are things that remind me of like
factions and World of Warcraft where you
level it up you unlock certain things
when you get to a high enough level cool
you've done enough okay now you've got
access to this thing or this weapon or
this mod or this spell book or whatever
it is
so these actually remind me of that
which if you enjoy that type of grind
they're kind of cool right so over N
it's just as you level them up the more
that you go play like nuts that's why my
focus has been more trying to get the
obelisks up so as you do other
activities like hey I got the strike one
up well every software honeybee strikes
now I'll get some fractal line and I'll
keep helping my own boys grind the lake
depending on how you want to play that
spreads why my video I put out there was
so freakin long I was trying to give you
the idea at which obelisk was going to
benefit your play style because if you
just love gambit well you should
probably just start with tangled short
exactly and that's the other point I
want to make is that the reason why I'm
actually having a little bit more fun
initially with this
I shouldn't say more fun but I'm saying
I'm having a lot of fun with this right
now is because one of my main complaints
was because of the pinnacle grind it had
eliminated the ability to do those other
activities but the obelisk and the
weapon bounties force you to do these
other things these activities still and
or they may say hey kill specific enemy
types which require you to now okay I
gotta go to trina city to get scorn or I
gotta go to tangle Shore like it's
making me go to different parts of the
map which makes the world feel more
alive but maybe it's just Bungie
tricking me and it just be fetched quest
in different places and it just but
heals better yeah it feels better it
feels better than just doing like just
doing sundown because the be honest I
thought it was gonna be due Sunday all
over four or five times hardboard
sundial that I thought it's gonna be
that kind of mean I think a lot of
bullet right so the fact that it I
really haven't jumped in the Sun down
too much because my thing is well let me
get these obelisks poppin right and then
maximize drop rates maximize efficiency
and then do that stuff and I think um
yeah but it's been really cool I like
this gameplay loop so far it's been
really surprising I didn't think I would
have this much enjoyment is it's less
grinding I don't know how I feel about
the little season of door mods yet I'm
not I'm not there yet out the better
yeah we touch dad I don't know how I
feel about that just yet I'm saying kind
of thing but
/ and I want to ask you this arm which
are the saint-14 weapons have you been
liking so far bill feathers even in PvP
not bad I was a mess it's probably not
godly but it hit some pretty hard and
quick like if they missed that like
opening shot you'll probably be able to
if you're fairly accurate put some work
into him with that one I haven't got
gallant charge
I know file I did a video over like God
Rosa no one looks like it's got some big
potential mmm I think what else I got
the linear fusion rifle it's fine it is
funny though when you're going through
heavy weight was on arcs and was on for
straights
Oh Lord it's like linear fusion I got a
head shot and I'm seeing numbers like
144 K 1 for time like oh I didn't think
our numbers went that high anymore so it
definitely can hit hard and then I was
doing I think we were doing the strike
playlist not me and just randoms and we
were on hash lagoon she spawned she died
I don't know what they hit her with I
don't know if it was like a well times
because I didn't see like the word cliff
coil like you can do like you've done -
what is his damn name on Mars I mean uh
Chris I've seen peanut melt knockers
that way but I don't know what killed
her so damn fast I was impressed though
jusers god I was like well that was
pretty good that was a quick strike yeah
rocking that out ah so those are pretty
cool I haven't even touched like the new
like the infinite past eight haven't
even touched the pulse rifle my go
figure still feels amazing so and that's
kind of the thing too is like when I get
into the pulse category something has to
kick out my go figure from my hand you
still rocking go brother pulses now has
anti barrier and unstoppable options
will you pick up a damn scout rifle we
don't try another kinetic please do
Scout rifles are popping right now bro
get you a light watch go get you a night
watch have your whole antsy night watch
you gotta get you a scout there's some
other ones too man there's only a galaxy
but I honestly like I still like my go
figure
fine we'll go one-on-one in PvP gear sky
first my pulse aha hallo sleep no sleep
is there an almost max range I piss
people off at farther ranges than I
should with that thing
believe me I know this boy is like four
seasons in would this day I took a break
I did that thing was parked in my vault
last season bro did you at least put a
big sigh can you put an exotic in there
put an exact try and exotic and connects
Yaffe don't Monte Carlo or have some fun
go smashing on Tyson I did that when I
had to get on my link melee kills for
that undying title
oh I lived with Monte Carlo for a while
I use some old purposes but if I'm just
like okay running around or doing Barry
just if I'm just gonna go random strike
playlist and I need more or I'm gonna go
into a match main nightfall yeah my
barrier go figure is just gonna go in
there so that's how that works
what was the West End Committee I mean
what's an energy excuse me uh usually I
live in there if I'm going PvE and I've
been still good morning people love it
what so what's this type of trade you
apostate but leveled you you uh I
probably don't have one that everybody
loves it's just if I'm in PE I have a
persuader that I absolutely love okay
it's I can double if I need to but I
have like moving target uh it's really
really really sticky like I'm sure I get
some major benefit from that one because
hold on I want to look at it because I
use it a lot uh in moving target
snapshot sites its handling I've got a
short zoom zoom tactical mag and then
I've got a target adjuster in there for
me it's just like it's stink it's pretty
damn good at PvP and I'm like I'm sure I
can put like ten sniper rifles in like a
really good person saying they're like
this one's trash but for me it works
well though no duh did you ever get the
the VEX offensive pulse that was a good
I actually got a damn good role in it I
think I have a feeding frenzy no and
I've actually been up and if I'm going
energy if I'm like flipping around
energy weapons or anything like that
I got a feeding frenzy multi-kill clip
it or ative like mag and extended barrel
a masterwork civet if I needed solar
kills that one switched in there so I
have used that one
oh so you're stuck in the pole I know
hella yeah I do like it pulses yeah you
you pull you're in a pulse crutch right
it bro I'm telling you the world is a
nice place with scouts out there you
gotta give Scouts a shot right there
they're mixing it up feel is good trust
me you gotta get 200 of them no no you
gotta get the two sixties or the two
hundred I'm telling you you got Randy's
right I did your auntie's bro don't tell
it's deceptively powerful the DPS is
sofa you're gonna think you're gonna
it's gonna be picking at them but you're
gonna be ripping through them you just
gotta get a good nice little roll man
I'm telling you lose that that much get
you away hopefully if you could get
something with a rapid hit and arm a
rack rapid hit kill clip or rapid hit
rampage on bro Scouts in PvE trust me I
don't like scouts like that and I'm
using it heavy man heavy I got a couple
of load outs right now you've been doing
that Lord of wolves obviously has come
back and force I've messed with symmetry
a little bit still don't I don't have my
timing with it I understand the weapon
yeah I like what it's trying to do I
just got an arm shout to scream bygones
with kill clip and full auto stuff yeah
yeah old-school dudes with these bygones
and I don't get these gold figures and
but tries put on a new outfit what that
is your new year's resolution for the
dawning try some new kinetics dammit
scream e all you guys run around these
old four season ago guns forever no
wonder why you guys have all those damn
upgrade modules yeah usually being saved
good rifles for the wind man if it works
out
thing because look at this new martyrs
retribution oh my god you guys killing
me kill you it is a fun new mariage
trust me even throwing an unstoppable on
mod on that Scout board man it's on out
here man finds the whole world and open
up for you trust me we'll just go ahead
and we got a one-on-one you're using
your Scout my go figure we're all play
it up we do I'm not sitting and I'm not
gonna say my PvP skills are gonna put my
gun to work but I would be I would be
curious if you could pick a scout and I
could put my go figure and say like true
Vanguard hands do a couple of matches
and see which one he gets more kills
with just to see I'd be curious I will
say this yeah - a trial user boom
yeah I'll be laying in people man from
distance we'll see we'll see how it go
man he said a good girl figures like Tom
Brady you may not like baby black thank
you but it's consistent in it with yeah
with these boring oh my look like don't
encourage him I will use my dad guns and
I'll wear my cargo shorts I got hope for
you bad you got your dad he said dad
guns my sandals I got socks with sandals
over here and you cannot stop oh my god
salut salut de wood that was the
funniest line of the jet you won you won
on now by the way if I had a blast
furnace that I had the roll I wanted it
that's what would get rid that's what
would actually get rid of my go figure I
haven't got my guys that's why I still
have my other one
but what's beset is using exotics in
kinetic that's that's was possible do
you know patch which was a really good
guy that pulse
compared to mine no it's not about yes I
should say or don't hate it cuz believe
me and does anyone I actually love that
gun no ranges that I'm used to working
with my go figure where I want that
accuracy to be okay nobody doesn't have
the range distance that consist if you
like one correct me if you're in that
auto rifle range yes
crime in it can put in some work in the
super so nice but it's like it cannot
touch me at the range that I can like
get you on so that's where no no I was
on the pole slate that's why I'm saying
for you to go Scout because I know you
you want that distance and that pinpoint
act we're getting gambit start font well
you can't really farm it because it kind
of have good places looking game the
guys play gambit get in there play game
about the rock again I'm all about
gambit now I'm out here in these
gambling streaks it's real I got serious
loadout in there you got and if I beat
you he's gonna take your people will
hose kid I use it exotic in PvP it's a
done in your kinetic swag damn it not
the tunngle or I use the kinetic
herbalist
yeah but you only doing that for like
two weeks and then after that you're
gonna throw that in the bushes as soon
as you get come on Oh whatever it is
that you out of here I know what you do
it but I Drive and say I'm like shadow
toppling so like when you get a feel for
it by your like hundredth kills ticket
not bad like people give a crap or you
hate getting hit by it but it's like you
actually get a like pre-charge to keep
your eye on the target like it's not
mm-hmm it's not the hardest thing to use
because it does have some aim assist the
flinch isn't as bad as a sniper but it's
also it's it's fun oh there we go mom a
dramatic outbreak let's go that's what
I'm talking about
Izanagi something please put it back you
just run around he of course they do
that yeah but you probably only do that
for pretty quick
I don't see you running around with
Izanagi less as a radio but that's fine
okay but I was like if I'm actually
gonna go trim I will if I'm going to
like a random strike playlist I'm just
like working okay solar up in here solar
here I'm not paying as much attention to
that but if I'm gonna go like hey I want
to go like break a boss yeah
isn't all you still gonna pop on there
oh yeah I know that's there one of the
best PvE pulses and DPS is in the game
and kinetic what's up don't tell me
you're like outbreak come on now well
then you're still talking about a
kinetic that's not izanagi's and you're
taking up my exotic for other things
it's not like you ain't got to god roll
swab of the Raven it's not like you
ain't got delirium 21% it's not like you
ain't got cricket Fame with that twenty
percent bro there is other heavies out
here legendaries are really good they're
really good dude we got to stop all this
dad bar loadouts now that's 20 damn bar
Nora's got to go 20 20 we're gonna start
it I want you to take a screenshot of
the year
I'll see you look calm this is a new law
Alma tried it and look about how much
fun you go I'm gonna brush me a sidearm
a slug shotgun and a sword just to piss
you off
speaking of which no you know what's
low-key really good and I'm forced to do
it for the catalyst Black Talon
don't catalyst video work Oh catalyst
wait what catalyst are you working on
blacks rustling chair
row that short not the projector I've
been killed by no very impressive ver
I'm starting to get a feel for it it's
it's thought it's moved up the hierarchy
by two number three number four exotic
it is really really cool but anyway
enough of that but Dad little more dad
bought stuff 20 20 try some new stuff
out get that Marta saw with retribution
out man if you get demolition I got
thick mines got underdog and um which
come moving target and that didn't you
already ought to do is just jump in the
air aim at the feet and just watch it
rip to shields and rip through boss
imagine targets very useful no no
yes and you're not trying to like hit it
harder you're trying to pick around well
that's true I just talked about the role
that I had syphilis I don't want moving
target our minds what I really want is
demolitionist that's the hell I'm going
for but um the put a free hand grip mod
on it though that's what you want but a
free hand grip mod on that bad boy shoot
at the feet and just melt people it's
like having a baby heavy man and it's
more effective than mountaintop because
if you miss it's more forgiving that dr.
my new Titans loved our mites oh yeah
I've been this was like that one that
one's not that new to me cuz I used that
grenade constantly
waves from s I only get one from that so
I don't know I just I got it all I have
more so I was like just being used to
thermite having like multiple waves when
I fire one I'm like oh that is just it
hold on I gotta fire again like you said
happening more frequently so the ones
you're gonna like about it the reload is
way faster than mountaintop so while
you're elevating it you can shoot one up
by the time you pick the apex of your
jump yeah I still haven't landed yet I
turned around to fight at this guy over
here and took him out oh and then this
guy over here now my feet finally touch
the ground
burns like two weeks but anyway but yes
that's that's that's what I'd be like of
mash out to be TP BPD he said the Ovilus
bodies being Peter was a bit ok she
thinks it started to grindy that's
things to what we think they think
they're to grandi uh almost brownies I
mean okay so here's the thing everybody
picks them up me like oh I need to grind
out these bounties all of them say
weekly so they're not meant to be that
bad but it's like it's also in the way
you do them though it's like hey go kill
125 cabal with a bow precision final
blows
go late okay so my advice on that one is
go do some law sectors or go do some
kabal strikes multitask while you're
doing it cuz once cabal for 125 with
Bo's one is just 300 cabal work on both
yes same thing if you got you know
you're rapidly defeat groups of three
enemies with a scout rifle Randi's is
great for this or actually the one
that's better I'll tell you this Jade
rabbit because then you don't have no
reload well daddy shows up yes right if
you need the three brave one stone Jade
rabbit works well cuz it's like body
head body head body head body head body
head body head buddy had still haven't
had to reload no no but like scout
rifles in hive mm-hmm escalation
vertical shoot a whole bunch of thrall
shoot him over and over I mean that's
tough so you can combine these bounties
but yeah if you're trying to grind all
three all eight on all three characters
it's a lot cuz I'm probably not gonna
get through all of them before I travel
I'm trying to give through my warlock
stuff but overall it's a lot I mean the
300 score and you got a run what does
that loss sector
drowned wishes in dreaming city yeah I
mean that's what you can you know and
you run it about six times and you're
done but what about the third one you're
like am I done
nope don't let them but what I like a
lot of these bounties can be done in
just the natural order of playing the
game yeah like if you have not like
specifically be like hey I have to go
grind out three hundred scorn right now
or if you go do a strike playlist
because you've got your vanguard thing
up and you're gonna get some donning
essence and some polarize fact line and
hey I got a scorn strike cuz I got hold
of l'air mm and if you're on a strike by
the way any of the ones where you need
like specific things I need triple scout
rifle kills you'll probably have to do
some of that on your own if you need
precision boca ball kills you'll
probably have to do that on your own a
little bit more but the ones where it's
cabal scorn high of those if you're
gonna strike your teammates count too
cuz i promise you i was not getting all
those kills and they were going up a
hell of a lot faster than I was shooting
so faster do some of that stuff with
groups better low-key Oh much better the
line well I was flying from multiple
bounties with scorn and in writing stuff
all at once
for I was in who's in well it would
depend on the week actually yeah that's
true too but yeah shoot so you have
those bound I mean the other art there
there grindy I mean they're meant to be
weekly but if you don't just try and
focus dead in on those like the Fallen
Capitol one yeah that one's there's no
fast way to do that I will shout out to
like my entire YouTube community this
has got to be the video I've ever put up
that has the most positive reception mmm
because I had like so many comments know
where to find fallen captains I finally
got one down though somebody ruined it
but I have 43 comments and almost all of
them are just really positive ways and
people saying hey I found him here I
found him over here this is where I
found him oh yeah this you took my spot
like all jokes like all positive stuff
that's like one of the rare times
somebody's just like well this is stupid
like I mean you're gonna have those in
there it's fine but like I have like 43
comments of people just saying hey I
work here this one works for me
I was just like if you ever need fallen
captains go look at that video and if
mine doesn't work for you there about 42
other options I know it's just like
that's cool that was actually really
cool that was a nice a nice little
positive reception on that one for
people
but I mean how much of those obelisk
bounties have you done
um most I mean I've done a lot of them
I'm still like maybe level II close to
nine on on Mars and then I'll think that
the next one I'll probably do is the
gambit one really really knocked that
one out
yeah I've been I've been having fun man
I got a serious load out right now but
gambit I cannot run gambit unless I'm
middle tree
um which call it arc you know dragon
yeah yeah bro I got a series you know
I'm saying I got Moscow burning the
invaders Lord of wolves just melting
fools melting yellows and then good old
delirium man
and I got some crazy a scavenger perks I
like one of my boots have like a machine
gun scavenger and shotguns scavenger and
one at the top I have like a basically
I'm never running out of Lord of wolves
well it's because I got it fully master
work I'm just creating orbs like a
maniac no um I'm able to invade you know
and um it's good I'm having so much fun
ECAM it Brown just melting stuff then I
get super all the time and if I run out
I got my little special finishing I'm
getting special energy but it's just so
much fun you know say I feel like that
build I could handle any situation and
I'm never an invading cry yeah but with
that build
what are you use on or say at Lord of
wolves or something farther I actually
took the room
okay little Aramis is a ste it picks
anything about it you don't gotta reload
with that thing you just walk over the
ground and delirium is very underrated
here's the key word I like about
delirium too people forget that what is
it uh killing tally or whatever it is
it's better than rampage because rampage
has that timeout but all you have to do
is kill like maybe one or two lesser
enemies it'll stay on
tally 3 killing spree type riah whatever
the thing is call now forever until you
run out of bullets so you're at that
maximum DPS so it's good for bosses good
for invaders it's just a nasty build man
I love it having a ball with that yeah I
got the catalyst for Lord of wolves
that's actually something we're gonna
find out and game but I totally forget
about that bro the stability is
ridiculous the real oh yeah the reload
so when you're in release the Wolves
more the reload now it's like gonna go
back to business back to boil and then
you get an orbs you can aw and then
think about this with chaos reefs and
topping off chaos reach some ankles were
super again delirium
oh let me get my skull you're down the
black oh yeah I can't see you oh you
tryin okay you trying to snag out on the
other side
mmm here's my Night Watch you wanna
snipe wanna pick a head nut bro gambits
prom I've from full-circle favorite bow
love it Wow bring on the gambit bring on
the pride tell me this says these are
words I did not expect to hear out of
you I've seen the light man I've seen
the light come around I see the light or
no some update module things yeah but
I've seen the risk oh uh yeah so I mean
no it's been fun the grinds have been
cool the weapons have been so far
entertaining the fusion gallant charged
father was saying like nothing's got
potential to be like 100 stable like
crazy good especially for those on
console wanna talk to you about these
mods the skinnies and have done armor
2.0 pods dawn armor I was actually
talking to my brother about this last
night too so I wanted to get your
thoughts about the whole seasonal mod
socket first exotics that don't have a
mod socket period and then these new
season of dawn charge with light the
price of them the type of use I know dad
I did a good video about those I mean
I've been staring at them too and I'm
just like what is gonna be worth worth
the benefit so kind of curious your
thoughts on those what are you thinking
so far sir good huh the thoughts nice
you know what I struggle with it's like
you got the two different categories the
one that puts you in the charge state
and then the one that does something
when you're charged yep right and
I don't know maybe is there a baby I'm
just playing stupid let me let me ask
you a little bit first when you are in
charter flight status I don't feel like
there is an indicator that lets you know
so it's bottom levels above you or it's
above
yeah I'm something down there okay is it
a timer debuff or is it it's a it's an
uh yeah it's static okay so maybe I just
gotta pay better attention but um listen
you know
but the cost of these things right
they're not cheap somebody effects a
really cool and you can make some krill
cool synergy with certain pills however
that then the problem becomes twofold
you said the exotic thing which actually
don't have a problem with the exact time
I know you don't like it but I know that
I don't have a fix your face I know it I
don't have the price it's not having a
nice seasonal slot
any exotic should be it should be able
to use these if you want us to try them
out
why are you not okay you're the one
saying hey uses exotic using exotic oh
you want to play the seasonal stuff well
don't use an exotic I'm just saying
using my words there here's the thing
let's be like we would never get off of
the exotics if that was half of the
exotic I suck anyway I need some reason
Liam busy try to buff these exotics of
each I get some functionality out of it
different exotics do you use when it
comes to armor up here see I'm a warlock
life is good for me
I got son braces but solar I got mom
geobags on my arm store what does it
just the trance did the night King one
but I got two feet right what I'm void I
got mine as effects in life is okay for
me I don't know about you Titans but for
me the only thing I will give you is
void fields I feel locked into Nazareth
cuz they kill skull of diamond Cara I
really don't use the other ones that
consistent so I will give you that void
me some more void exotics to really help
me out a little bit but but like Ark I'm
out here baby Geo mags and the de storm
called the UH okay but if you want to
season it on mod then you can't use any
of the things you just said yes you can
you have to use it in your other slots
so how about you make another outfit
right that just is season at door stuff
that is a rounder is at it so keep the
exact you like and then move around
you're like
no I was looking because one of them was
you what mod was I looking at
was like a helmet mod but it was
something else I was looking at with my
brother hmm something had a specific
spot I was looking at Rosalie oh no is
that no it was the
well you still got the class item yeah
and for other seasons of doing slots
besides the exotic like yeah hey use it
no I understand that
trust me but you also get to the point
of like how much are you maxing out
these armors for are you gonna spend
like okay so this is a season and this
is where the debate comes up and this is
why I bring this up you have season have
gone ok don't want to use these mods
well someone over my like three or four
or five energy to us and if you're gonna
use those you're gonna kind of [ __ ]
the ability to use anything else in
there without kind of leveling and I are
you mister in the currencies to level up
a dawn piece of armor no no I'm saying
are you gonna spend your golf balls and
your shards
were you getting golf balls are you
doing 980 night falls out here oh you
mean oh I'm not I mean at the golf ball
my bad you're right I'm not the golf
ball yeah I got three golf balls I've
never touched I'm not in yellow
screaming from the season place and
that's the only place you got right
exactly
inside you Jay so you're right about
that but you don't level up what so what
you keeping stuff at like four or five
charge what is your armors not like my
like seven maybe eight max okay don't we
in the same pocket is so if you're
taking stuff seven eight so you mean to
tell me you can't take a season of the
dawn legendary armor up to seven eight
and just have that piece I'll take it
success said I would take it to seven
cuz eight you're six or seven yeah yet
like I can use cores cuz I have plenty
mm-hmm Charlie prisms I won't do I
figure so that's like absolutely in love
with it and you look at some like the
ones that are the ones of these that I
want to use are gonna cost me five so if
I go five that takes it down to a mod
with two and that's not a lot of
outcomes depending on where you go right
so I'm just so it's more like how much
are you gonna put into the dawn armor
with these mods are they cool are they
do pricey or you just broke all the time
well I'm broke all the time we saw you
but big is this right you gotta have
multiple like armors for like like when
I get a legendary piece
I'm looking at the stat rope and I'm
going according to my place they all so
fast lately by the way don't they well
if you've been playing iron banner and
if you play sorry no no I'm saying this
season is an art that's another reason
why I haven't upgraded any of them every
stat role isn't in like five zero or bad
trash
I agree but that's why I'm not gonna
upgrade it then I can't usually dawned
on our months without spaghetti crazy
here's alternative is what you do you
remember now gambit crucible and
Vanguard all have the dawn flight now
you just reacquire it so those are
dropping with the good rolls and I'm
using those but I mean I've been getting
good ones in gambe it wasn't crucible I
don't know how I'll be at least at least
in the kind of snap categories I want
might have been my my armor this season
if I click on it and that's been trash
almost not all of that attributes you
want give me let's break it down first
list okay let's see here we go I bought
this is placed at 50
I'm not upgrading that 51 I get that
okay I get that yeah let me ask you this
question what are the stats that are
them give me the three stats that are
the most important to e Bacchus right
yeah probably it depends on if I'm doing
PvE or PvP uh it's splitting fine like
resilience or recovery a little bit of
both but recovery I don't care as much
about mobility or strength when it comes
to PvE okay so dou Z at three right so
you never get a fifty four or fifty five
with three of those categories with a
twelve or higher I'll be getting that
all the time
must be nice oh my god damn you must
have orange easy saying like you Oh I'll
be getting fifty tools and fifty fours
or sometimes like that without a mod and
then it did sometimes happen get some
dare boots that I'm looking at that I
went upgrade one okay there you go and
then what I usually do is whatever the
one out of the three right those are
your three you said recovery resilience
and was it discipline was it the
intellect would be good for supers if
you're gonna land but this guy's like
this one that I got this pair but this
is one I would literally one I would
almost max out to mobility to string go
13 routine recovery 13 discipline 12
intellect that is my one role like that
everything else has been so bad however
here is that this is how this is lit
can't help you now now you you're right
that you're not gonna get all the time
that is like ridiculous specific to what
you want that's not gonna happen what's
gonna happen warm times out of not not
is the two out of the three so what you
do is then for that third one let's say
the intellect is missing hey let's go
put this four in here or this recovery
put that recovery modern you know put
that intellect mod in it so now you've
balanced out that's that
there you go I understand how the system
works
I'm not dumb I know how the function
works I got eight he'll Rob's a drop
that had 46 stats and then I got an
exotic that had 50 game dude it does not
like me this season I don't get it Lily
I don't have that type of look listen
I'm
and many more thank you - since dawn
wants I'm like thank you I maybe am i
that lucky like I've been getting stuff
flying out here man
yes I mean I'll get happy seeing
everything you buy upgrade modules so
you don't care yeah listen I or you just
like all put on there oh yeah it's got
like 64 stats no no no the base sucks
that's the day sucks yeah could be like
959 959 let me look let me upgrade
everything put these mods in here oh I
got 960 let me upgrade put everything
put these mods you only do that when the
three are met or two of the three that I
like that are very high so for me right
now it's melee because a top tree arms
Dom blade arm resilience and recovery
those are the three I'm going crazy for
right now right now so if I get two of
the two let's say I get one with a
20-something melee and just one of the
other two is missing then I'll just put
them on in and you could to go
you can't just be living around like not
playing the game because the gods have
not blessed you with Orangina like that
like you like I refuse to spend any
money because the guys have not giving
me the kind of armor I like using all
the stuff that we're doing you don't
need to spend your currency on that if
there is something else not even playing
the new features of the season like you
are so stingy see that I'm gonna get at
you cuz yeah I talk about me not spend
you are so stingy
you're not even trying the new stuff
until you get the most new mine yes I'm
glad I tried am i traveling toward him
the one when you got the ATM at all when
you look at the vendors and you're gonna
bind those mods they're 10 mod
components per mod if these are done
only mods do we keep them are they going
away question and if I'm gonna if
somebody buys all the mods and that's
120 mod components and it's a seasonal
thing mm-hmm I have a lot of Bob
components but that's the shout out to
fort a gold play reckoning heist at
armor for days
yep dramatic Dunn's you know I'm a
better stats than the one barely yes if
this is you this is an e problem I know
cuz I'm gonna do this no way my orange
is better than y'all you play way more
hours than me so you've got your orange
because I'm apparently Hitler wrong
actor how objectivity you son playing
gamer Prime you haven't been playing
reckoning there's the difference true so
I can play yeah yeah how were your drops
is this where you're getting all this
magical greatness that's where I was
getting the UM cuz I remember I was
trying to form spare rations and Night
Watch and the other machine gun yeah I
was playing so maybe that's where these
magical drops are coming from so that
hell could be there yeah and then
somebody's saying that dungeon water to
my dungeon dropped last season pissed me
off
yeah cuz I got a 51 base roll stat out
of the pinnacle dungeon boss roll
fifty-one base it was master worked to
sixty master worked to 63
so is 51 base and I get it in in 63 and
it's fully master it feels like oh my
damn it sucks
yeah shots of javadi do you have mod no
minashi I got some old stuff yeah so
let's bring up with the fabulous dinners
but that's what the obelisk wants you to
do it
well it doesn't totally reckoning or
other things that does say the menagerie
actually mmm just kind of one of those I
net it may sound like I'm complaining
but it's also just when you look at like
dad oh did a really good break out on
these mods he's like which ones are
worth it and you're like okay so I need
to get charged with flight well what's
the best way to get charged with played
by the mods that you can buy I would
probably say it's the most expensive one
gonna cost you five energy right in
every rapid defeating of enemies with a
fusion or a shotgun probably gonna have
a little lot in PvE
and then you could stack on the one mod
where every time you get a stack of
energy you get an extra stack mm-hm and
then you could choose which one you want
to spend on the other side but it's like
if you start using all those mods you're
starting to take away like your
intellect monster now going away so your
stats are getting lower yeah you're
taking away your reload speeds your
unflinching is like the trade-off of the
price of some of these new mods for
builds I'm not sure I love the cost of
some of these things is what I'm kind of
eventually getting to is like in costs
how much energy one of the dam mods cost
seven that's as high as some of my
armors are gonna go especially if it's
dawn specific I'm not gonna waste golf
balls or prisms on something that
potentially is anyway to them at all you
you be hoarding all right no about you
you are never spending there's never an
ideal situation for you Meyer but we got
a good roll I'd love to upgrade at one
point I got like that 57 that I'm
looking at I'm really debating on it cuz
I'm staring at like that is actually
perfect for me and I'm just like you
know but all these modules and these you
know what what are you to do with all
500 masterwork cards that you're gonna
oh my god when you just take four of
them out and oh my god Oh ridiculous
this week but you know what yes yes we
both have our day we are both or
polarizing size of ridiculousness I
spent too much you know thing about that
that bugs me it's like I would take that
one to send them like as soon as I log
into the game for my Titan I've just
been playing on my warlock this week um
but if I take that one to like seven I'm
sitting there thinking of my head I'm
like do I spend prisms or a golf ball on
this thing knowing in two buds that it's
gone that's like stat rule the steps but
that's pretty good and it's void it's
actually like nice for the right type of
things
now this is where me and you are at
agreement
where they gonna get into a little
problem with the seasons is because they
every season seems so specific for vets
but like a specialty mod per season
right now we're talking about like we're
getting into that territory where it's
gonna be hundreds of arbors that are
specific and then it starts to get a
little messy right so they're gonna have
to some things are going to have to
stick around I feel because every season
we can't always have a specific mod
right every season we have leg how many
of these season I mean you have to buy
twelve the dawn mods that's not cheap
alone that's a hundred and twenty mod
components to buy those things you're
like okay so I do buy all of those then
do I need to keep three types of donning
armor to be able to use all of those
things okay then
last season I don't want to get rid of
all my dream Bane stuff or I'm working
in the dungeon I'm working on the moon
I'm getting some dream bane things those
are undying okay so I'm getting those
mmm how many armors mods how many sets
of armor do I need to keep now when we
talked about not really needing them
much anymore much less the like Armour
affinity of arc solar and void and the
next season we're gonna have whatever
it's called armor socket this is a
different accounting problem and this is
the like like at some point I'm like so
whether it's the affinity goes away and
then it's just they're easier to use so
if you get a cool drop for the season
great or the mods don't need to have as
much of an affinity but you can only
print like like some of the newer perks
but the other ones like this seasonal
mods having an affinity that bugs me
that's like gives you two specific the
only one you realization is the taking
charge like pick up an orb of light and
then the one where you also just like
get extra damage on your next like once
you're charged when you when you do
damage you do 20% more damage and you
could just like not even think about
that one pass them through and it would
just have four at a time
but other than that like some of these
are really specific and I like I bought
one of them
Solar armor mods and then I was like hey
let me go put this on
have a solar dawn piece yet I can't even
use it and I was just like are you
kidding me that was like early in the
season I've got a couple drops now but
like that early I was like are you like
I can't literally buy the thing I just
like it use the thing I just bought
though not that that is a problem that
is the long-term problem the day gonna
have to figure out because we can't be
like you know the next three seasons and
a set of you know six to seven armors
like we you know sitting in man that
we're not able to be using anymore based
on activity so yeah there's some distant
validity there for say saying I would
never upgrade seasonal armor most likely
won't be relevant the next season which
it said vagabond Oh said he hasn't spent
a prism or a signature since shadow keep
dropped the only thing I've pretty much
gotten close to is by um default or what
you call it up the one that carried over
to 2.0 there had to flame Solstice yep
even have that great of a stat role I
thought must not rule the decent for my
playstyle and they had the solar a lot
of them had solar based a warlock yeah
you did
yeah so for me it was it was perfect and
then it kind of kept with me weird it's
like I sit there and I look in some I'm
like yeah I'll kind of goof around with
mods I don't use the art the seasonal
mods and stuff like that in there and
the seasonal mods are kind of cool but
it's just the and this little son with
my brother about is the idea of lake
spinning this time to get a set of
seasonal armor then you have three
different sets of seasonal armor if you
have a character that you have nine sets
of seasonal armor and then at the end of
the season that mod slide goes where
potentially goes away either loses its
function we don't know if the charged
with light thing is gonna be a thing
they try no or is that even gonna stay
around and then if you get a similar and
you do it all over again you're like and
how much time to wanna put into it how
much do I want to invest into a system
if I don't even know how long it's gonna
stay around but the key comes down to
Shanta Forge they say you got seventeen
golf poles and way too many prisons to
count you need to give me a long-term
reason I play normal which is east point
and I definitely understand it the key
for them is they've got to figure that
out they've got to figure out more usage
for that or come up with a solution for
something maybe you know you get your
wish with the exotic armor being the
rotational piece or whatever you know
but they gotta come up with something
because that he said to utilize all that
material and then for the next season I
for example let's say you you maximize
all that dream pain stuff from shadow
key right and that's like you ain't
going to the moon now you ain't doing
that stuff now you know I'm saying like
so it's not gonna hold the same weight
you know that build those buffs and and
the other thing comes down to let's be
real like these buffs better be
substantial for you to even want to
invest so if they're not substantial and
right now the jury's kind of I mean yeah
like I mean that'll did a good breakdown
I've looked through most of them and I'm
wondering I'm like what is really worth
my time to build like a set of armor
over man it's rent I mean the ones that
I could see function out of hmm there's
not a ton
I mean healing yourself with a grenade
flannel blow it'd be nice
me but it's like are you gonna wait and
depend on it mmm the one where you have
more damage resistance when you like
lose your shield in PvE it would be cool
to stay alive if you're trying to do
like a solo build but then in turn if
I'm doing a solo do I just want more
resilience and recovery and intellect
just to get things back more frequently
like where is the trade of the mods
themselves the system in theory is kind
of cool to get yourself charged up but
and then to use it you only get two
charges which is really annoying as a
cabbage of two you can get a monster you
can have three but it's weird you can
also get a mod so every stack turns into
two but I think in theory would be
better to have the mod on where you take
every snack that you get - - every time
mm-hmm
and you always use the double so that's
two mods one to get the charge even just
by say picking up an orb of light
another mod so you get the double every
time and then something to use it if
you're looking at three mods to get
decent use out of that system and you're
just starting to take away the use of
other things I get it I get it man I get
it I may be like I said the cost has to
go down the vibe I'm getting it this is
still very experimental oh yeah as far
as like they are playing around they're
still figuring this thing out with 2.0
as far as these mod slots and they've
gotta just fine-tune I think the ideas
in practice and in theory they sound
good but in practice not necessarily all
the way there yeah I think they're
afraid of just making anything - too
strong too broken yeah this is what it
is yes there was a fro because this
one's like striking light for example
kind of a cool sounding one while
charged with light defeating enemies
with melee damage and sword spawns an
orb of light for your allies and
consumes one stack of chart to play if
you on this piece of art it takes five
arc energy to use this
hey if you have a narc another arc mod
on whatever piece of armor you put this
into hmm you gain damage resistance
again non Guardians while sprinting so
you need MELAS or swords you got to get
close if you combine the arc mod you
sprint and you get in there and you're
able to do this like in theory that
sounds cool then you rank an orb and
then if you're playing with friends then
hey you make an orb so hey if I'm
playing with you and we know this every
time I pick up an orb I'm getting our
buff light we share this thing we're
luncheon we're using swords maybe you're
using your black Allen because you're
having fun with it like there aren't
ways to do this but it takes a whole
hell of a lot of coordination to make
some of the payoffs happen and that's
where it's for just an average like
casual who logs in they're not gonna see
the benefits out of this stuff probably
sees it
Agron I which game comes down to course
match all right that means you either if
you're gonna keep that course then the
the effect has to be greater or if it's
gonna stay where it's at then the cost
of the energy has to be lower
you know sale we can still utilize other
things you know yeah one two maybe three
but like some of these being five or
five seven on what it's like yeah that's
your creeping into the territory of lake
especially for a temporary thing you're
not letting me explain if it was say
this was the dawn armor mod and say they
were cheaper now hey we want to bring
some of these back some of this is cool
we've kind of adjusted summer a little
more but they're permanent so if you're
gonna build around them you have them
forever then it might be a little more
on file but when they experiment I think
a lot of this stuff should be cheaper
same thing with the artifact some of
that stuff's too much I will never use
that camera I will never use the heavy
I'm not a finisher I'm not use ever I'm
not using its in it I'm not that's a
whole set it's on this lot mmhmm yeah
I'm not and it's half your damn super
it's too expensive for us yeah no only
heavy that bag composed is heavy and
we'll finders there's other things in a
game I'm getting heavy all the time
there's no need for me to do that
sometimes I'm swimmin sometimes it's
feast or famine I feel like sometimes
I'm like looking down I'm like how do I
have like eight heavy bricks on the
ground in this game I step in here what
Massacre just occurred
other times I'm like I have like one
bullet left in my machine gun how did I
do here it's like it's a tale of new
times but it's so weird
mmm a favor it's gotta be vagabond Oh
sharp flavor it's got to be sword kills
it sounds too much like it matches me
yes sir
not too much on spoilers in case you
guys haven't got there but what are your
thoughts of where we're currently
sitting in the story mode of we're like
hey go do this thing knock out these
little pieces one of which by the way
the one in the tangle when I made my
little video about finding the planting
the transponders that one where I see
people doing circles I'm like I think I
know where it is I know it Dallin yeah
and found that - the blueberries shout -
the blueberries out there but around
Estes that bill was good or because I
know where they're going and I'm like oh
the ground but I can't tell you because
you're not a charlatan in text chat I
love it but yeah your question was a
reference to just exactly oh just a
story just like the grind wasn't that
was just made me laugh when I got there
was like yeah people are gonna struggle
at this one but then when you get done
then you go to then you start the store
and you're like all this a sick and then
you get to the end we go through the
story by the way
so cool that was a hell of a fight man
like how is that story mission fight
better than some strikes shreya just
blatantly it was cool you had him
messing with you sniping you kind of
like the pyramidion guy then he'll can I
go behind this wall he'll get a big
Minotaur that you got a knockout well
other guys are coming through you got a
bigger space to work with which I like
more freedom I love that Loki packed
little every boss fights gotta be in the
circle so you can never hide and that's
mentality I really got tired of you
looking in there not with the open done
so cool I'm not gonna spoil it because
you guys have you haven't played it you
need to but now we're at the sling
is it the next week do you think is it
later like our as you phrase that the
blue balls cliffhanger type thing yeah
steel in those words from you but it's
like do you think there's an issue with
the storytelling of like we used to be
able to log in ago story story story
story story knock it out right and now
it's like here's the story wait a week
okay well the sundial needs to charge up
again so you have to wait seven days
before you can okay the sundial charged
up again you did your thing well now
things happen rounds at you Oh French
looked at you perplexed Osiris says I
like that he can't talk sometimes he
said you have to you have to look at his
feeling but man is back but damn it can
we not know about his facial expressions
every five minutes
we've got dope my recording gets to a
certain point so we have a alright 90
second spoiler talk is gonna happen
right now
okay so when we Lang when we get done
fighting the giant Minotaur we flip spot
saint-14 bust us out of there which is
absolutely freaking amazing when he
walks out where is the bro hug between
Osiris and Saint why did that happen now
no love no love like a tease out he's
out he's I yo I'm out there was no movie
like I was like okay sitting he's not in
the tower he is no I'm like did I miss
part of the story did I not go talk to
him why is he not he was over there I
walked over there he could walk out with
like a horse it is great let's do the
tower Lake to the tower yeah award said
a wave our arms when we're done with
them spoilers I'll get their part yeah
so we'll do a wave when it will let you
know but um yeah man
that part was again wouldn't it picking
let's beyond for women picking this
submission was amazing we got 30 seconds
but yeah what we got correct so mission
was amazing I love that but we would go
back to the scene of the crime you know
he gets to the finish it was tremendous
you come out he does what he does very
tightly no bastok all
much sass on that anything was great so
now we just have to see what happens and
getting just big missus more opportunity
there yeah well yeah oh really bring
down all I have I'm hoping that you know
we will have some type of contact you
know I'm saying based on this and that's
it but um yeah great overall just a
slight miss moment of something
fantastic
alright award we're back come back come
back spoilers over spoilers done yeah I
mean overall the mission itself amazing
fight and stuff like that and then what
happens in the end it's just like the
weekly structure of these things feels
like they're they're really pulling at
that thread to be like hey you gotta
wait a little bit longer to see what
happens it's like why this is like do
you so do you like the weekly or do you
wish like we could progress through the
story at our own pace so like do I want
to knock all the story out in a day or
do you feel like this strip the thread
is like being a little extra stretched
it is a little extra but I don't mind it
I don't want to you have to do it with
the predicament near it you know saying
because of again resources I get it they
get the key with them remember we see
each it's like each season it getting a
little better and a little better and a
little better but they miss this and he
missed that but you know we talked about
the star great opening cinematic to get
people hype for the season just wish
that was in-game right then doing this
amazing story missions audibly some of
the best in the game just tighten up a
little bit on the transition when the
big event ends so it's a little bit more
cohesive that's all I think what just
won't buy hug the bro hug yeah I get it
so my thing is all they now it's cool or
like that that threading they just got
it's like you know they it's like they
give us something stopped abrupt
give us something stop abruptly just got
a seamlessly straight thread this thing
together make it nice and then it's go
but I'm confident I gonna do it because
they hear our complaints though they're
the biggest thing I feel is how much we
complained about the undying mind
I think that threw them off they thought
things like yeah this is it no this is
not him don't ever do that again
don't you ever undying mind us again
right so if you built them up like this
so that I think the key is remember this
season adorned shadow keep with Bill
together right now we have the next
season and I got I want to jump into a
TAS he's saying real quick because at
the end of the day I do think based on
what happened in Assam
okay I know this territory I think he's
on to something because we don't know we
sill we are looking at that robot like
what the hell is Imperium whatever all
right right so now it becomes look we
all know trials is coming back let's
just not even Charles is coming is the
older cards and other such stuff
everything's out there right so now I do
subscribe our to Paul taciturn man it's
article I am subscribing to the we are
gonna build or we're gonna construct the
new trials but whatever it is and maybe
this is where narrative Lee you know you
boy my it's my holder place it might be
I'll be he's got the voice for it we got
that we got the t's during mission to
yeah you know it's
it sounded like very announcing to me he
was talking doesn't like her leg it was
like Rory I read the article I just
heard it and I was like that's kind of
funny like mmhmm I was thinking that cuz
he I'm like I'm literally being cheered
on so at the end of the day I think
they're building something towards that
narrative Lee again cohesive pay it off
right and then I'm fine I'll be good
with that I'll be really good with that
I'll be really but also we gotta get
look I know Titans this is all about
y'all this is the Titan DLC I get it you
know zan I just need a proper payoff
like I said the bro-hug for my man
something with my man's like I just
don't want
he narrative Lee what happened at the
end of curse of Osiris with Osiris I
don't want a Medusa's and redeeming
cleanness nothing we need to get secure
where is Segura Osiris we have not heard
the actress like again I get it my man
has to play backseat to your man your
man's to showcase showdown I get it
I just need a proper payoff no probably
you get the bigger but yeah she we gotta
get her back um you know we got to get a
proper conclusion for the boy even if he
gonna go back on his infinite force trip
again or whatever is he do but just
don't do sis us like you did at
Christmas iris and there's no ammo even
with a cord it was no emotional nothing
it was just alright you know you look at
though you muted you look at his smile
and um now is it you read it
oh I was just gonna say it's like what
if he does what if he just deuces you he
goes back in the infinite forest and
just like I'm nervous I gotta stay on
patrol I am NOT allowed battle you know
why I'm nervous
first of all his NPC says exiled world
former Vanguard like they're letting you
know he ain't coming back right okay
fine
but what really makes me nervous is when
you go to him he's not like any other
MPs which means stop with this wall
about man is the DLC game before Taylor
hunter mouth anyway your mandate moving
on we waiting for waiting for the hunter
Vanguard we wait for the red oh my man
Oh Jen all just solve this did the truth
I still wanna see how that story goes
down
this is ghost baby this is ghost named
whatever violet was it whatever so shout
out to that ghost they brought back the
real hunter [ __ ] I'm Bob Pisgah wait
for game of what they didn't respond yes
body badly
I want to get his blood boiling but
anyway ballpark there we go pork chop
pork yeah there we go there we go say
any witness at the end of a shout-out to
y'all but um dick did you think got a
pad off we got to do that right and I'm
saying and at the end of the day I was
nervous because when you talk to him he
isn't he a weird MPC doesn't have static
categories but it's just a blank screen
side up and then there's there's nothing
and I'm just like oh you already setting
it up that you ain't gonna be around but
they got a paid off right like anyway
apparently were like NBC's don't have
much to do bro she was shining for a
little bit doing fexif acer she feel
good to get bounded from it yeah and
then when undying mine came you're like
get out of here I don't I don't need to
talk to ya
ah dramatic war like life representing
there we go there's no locks but yeah
that's it but um look it's gonna be
interesting to see more free arena
burger oh yeah that's I said get all the
love interest in Dan pool oh yeah she
cost money she ain't on a budget that's
what it is I was like oh [ __ ] yeah he
who I have no ghost no I - Oh dancer he
it's gonna be him myself
that'd be that but um yeah I just the
payoff got to be cool I think that's
what we're definitely we're definitely
setting up some trials for the future we
we're creating it or establishing it the
new threat and what do you let me ask
you this you know we talked that I've
been rambling about Osiris Saint what do
you think happens man I don't know I got
his little shotgun propped up in the
tower or accidentally floating in the
tower I don't know why it's there I
don't know if it's like a joke cause we
like broke time and his how his that's
like his spot in the tower but not
really but then he's just chilling out
hanger in a weird-ass spot anything
exist in this timeline with Zavala he's
gonna go into Spartan his butt off that
tower list he's gonna sit out there but
what's the heart let me ask you this
Titans
what's the hierarchy there like as far
as your favorites you know say this out
his balls on the bottom it damn
what alright so be a [ __ ] is this asked
a real question
shacks and you made salad where's that
ranking
that's alright no y'all putting saint-14
what would i would see when it was safe
for Tina's clearly established himself
as titans Mane's number one favorite
tight
oh you look on Twitter people are saying
in that in people like hey no Sh axis
Bey there's a lot of people that have
300 yeah there's a lot of back and forth
I'm like no don't you talking about my
sex like that so I'm like Jax's Texas
legend its that'd be that'd be a fun
like one-on-one match to see like I
write one crew like to crucible matches
or something like that you see who's
going to I don't know like both both are
at least cool like I mean Shaq's is
awesome there's a cool there was
actually a GDC Game Developers
Conference like video but one of the
Bungie devs went down and explained how
the character of Shaq's was built really
because he's not really ever been a
character he's never been in story
missions or anything but we feel like we
know him better than most and it's like
the announcing he does in there the
voice lines he has loved the actors like
Shakespearean like classically trained
so stuff like yeah so they go through
like how they take like just an NPC and
build an announcer quote announcer into
a character and there's actually really
cool things and go look up like one of
the Bungie ones a GDC I don't was the
last year the one coming up whenever it
was that was really cool to see about
Shaq's because they they go through and
they're like how to make an announcer
cool and like when they started out they
showed some of his lines he's like a
good job Guardians and it's just pretty
chill in like the early part and it
wasn't until either taking king of rise
of iron they showed when they started
giving him like a motion that didn't
that didn't come about at first and when
he took over and like started building
that character it's been really cool to
watch and then you see the scene of
evolution that was cool
I don't know just seeing that about
shacks is actually really awesome but I
mean st. hasn't been here that long
I knows the fall is like me save the
tower he's this guy but dude you get him
you got a buck up at some point if you
want to if you want to stand in the
tower with the other two that are in
there now he's gotta get his act
together at some point
Gibby he's gotta have some either
sacrificial or a Gore badass moment in
like destiny 3 he's gotta earn his
stripes again because right now he has
been demoted a couple times in my head
we we get it my question Dallas where
you at with the salad and then shacks
and so salad is your third no man salad
salad and his fire hammer and he'd taken
on like the wall and the fight of six
fronts and fighting Siva like he did an
awesome job
I don't know dude all of those are
awesome I can't place all of them okay
just keep surviving easy with this late
I take him over to overrated exact exile
scared to come to the tower quiver and
big what are you talking about for the
first of all my man left the tower
because you fool to listen to that
faceless idiot that false prophet who
got murdered in the red war was faded of
the The Charlatans that's the speaker
yeah nobody misses the speaker I think
that's how Larry like Osiris came up to
town he's talking like it's a regular
day nobody put a gravestone
nobody shed a tear but a false prophet
you notice that don't you find that
quite hilarious like we more decayed
everybody got somewhat of a mourning
right you know who got more shine then
then there's a speaker remember when we
did the Haunted for us and they killed
master ives from the got ball of a
burial he got the twelve gun salute the
speaker so that's why my man left
because you guys are idiots he knew the
VEX is real you know I'm saying
so yeah just wasn't on his wavelength
you
oh yeah not realizing what the true
threats are I'll add me when you do then
y'all built this stupid thing our quarry
built in guess what my man is that back
to save y'all from which I did so that's
the answer to that question but back to
you Saladin well there Sullivan Swilley
and checks I don't know I haven't
thought about this
teller tough choice rap guns utility his
favorites Frankham come on Yuri tighten
me come on now for my experience that
I've got and from what I've seen
the shacks ain't
salad
Wow I was surprised and think you do
that that's the father did you'd have
Saladin I don't we a lot of salad Titans
man salad in our shacks right some spot
for Saladin it does it dumping I'm not
saying you're probably the first I've
heard say that my head I'm like thinking
through Dusty's history and again this
is where Shaq's hasn't got the love of
what he's done
he is reducible owner but like Saladin's
out there fighting the wolves and Siva
right cause you see he's part of the
iron Lords like so say that is like we
had all of that awesome back story of
what they went through and everything
and that's was like
he comes every so often buzz like fur
character Laura story
I think Saladin's mold we don't have as
much on shacks we know his crucible guy
and there's probably plenty of lore I'm
missing and then st. while being awesome
it sounds like he's one of the best of
all time we don't know him that well yet
so currently just of current base
knowledge and stuff maybe st. will come
back and take them all out but for the
time being I'll just I would put I would
put the every so often
seasonal visitor of salad and um yeah I
know everybody's like really salad bar
up there yeah oh my WD proceed we back o
Hattie's Osiris landed messages in hit
this is not allowed on the last word he
said technically we've now are fixing
his problem because he left the sundial
alone and the Kabbalah is figured out
how to use it so basically we're
cleaning up the mess again didn't
actually yeah I cleaned up no mess first
of all yeah broke the tail on it okay
well we go to mercury and you play those
strikes and we're literally saying hey
yeah another version of The Times broke
is like why are you doing this is like
work oh I figured the Guardians could
fix it he keep does keep breaking stuff
that we do have to fix every time
resistor bring your man back who
constructed this device to bring your
man back who attempted to bring your man
back I'm not saying but like okay so
long they can't be some mistakes along
the way of trying to save someone from
death from a time broken things to you
were just saying he didn't break
anything I'm like every time you play a
garden world we're reminding he broke
something just for us to play that
strike again listen things happen but
what man is the Prophet or seen these
things alright now we got the God you
know the Guardians supposed to be joking
now know that Christmas present for you
with the Christmas brother Vance robe
yes yes the crazy
disciple kool-aid you are like the or in
the Alerus all praises be salute was
seen it saxis of odana going in on Shaq
Shaq has a private time with me tomorrow
maybe not I'm poor but cannot be looked
over trying to show you shot Jax is a
Mandalorian never takes his helmet off
yeah mmm this is the way any word this
is the Westers do it easy Bon Jovi was
the word you say it with me guys that
listen to a fourth problem you guys got
fooled you're all you got to stay in and
got fool that's not my fault you're
listed for profit my man knew what Tama
was you know listen to them fake
reverence preaching that nice anyway
moving along the darling is going on we
got some cool ornaments so you're gonna
get your ice skating finisher I don't
often get a couple weapons ship that's
out there is pretty cool overall mostly
all cosmetic stuff spend the money if
you want to if you don't you don't bake
some cookies do all that stuff but again
the big ones try and get your avalanche
roll and your cold front train get those
weapon rolls as much as you can got I
got the cold front randomly very early
but I got a little like my first package
I got a roll did my first package same
thing up it was like a great roll - Oh
mine was none somebody was like hey is
this first girl supposed to be this good
and they were like kill clip in lake it
was a process like god I guess a moment
I guess in movie kill clip with the
first word I'm like okay is this just
where my orangie hates me
yeah I got Zen moment osmosis II yeah
again
orangey not my fan but for years festive
Christmas holidays we've got iron banner
and the Valor bonus coming there is
gonna be a new seasonal pursuits another
armor set based on it each step will
award iron banner weapons and armor
they'll have a little longer pursuit it
sounds like it will be cared
they did also say for all of you that
we're hoping as you guys can see the
graphic the graphic on the calendar
shows a bow it is not coming around this
season now why do you think a bow
wouldn't be able to make it him what do
you think why is just a bow if they had
like a model almost ready
like is it perks is it a heavy that they
were afraid it was gonna break something
like why would a bow not make it him
it's just weird again this this season
the only thing I can attribute is yeah
they but have a lot of puffs whatever
reason with this specific concert this
is probably the most glitches I've seen
and it's gotta be something game
breaking but I may even think about it
cuz it makes no sense why what is
there's nothing that should prevent it
from being in this season so yeah it's
like it's just a weapon archetype but
unless it just has like it can roll with
a perk some perk on a bow is just crazy
I don't know I can't figure out why
doesn't mean they they daily said it's
not coming which is good I got ahead of
it as most of you people like I saw in
the picture why isn't it there well it's
not
they did change an arsenal of tricks the
bounty the requirements have been
reduced by half I think that was the
slow grind for everybody
Pinnacle's will be going 970 max power
so you guys are gonna be able to get
higher it will be off for seven but
there will be seven bounties offering
pinnacle rewards but only four are
available per event so at least it won't
be always the same [ __ ] which is nice
little variety there mm-hmm and then
other than that all the rewards will be
weapons until the seasonal pursuit has
been completed well overall usual iron
banner stuff but you know if I'm
traveling for like four days so I don't
know how much of this I'm gonna get to
play which is sad but I'll get what time
and I can
they did get a hotfix in their PC
settings aren't switching every time you
log in thank goodness that was getting
old knowing uh overall though the Dynamo
mod breaking thing that's been fixed
they know of a couple of other issues
honestly nothing seems to terribly
broken just the EDC they're aware of it
if you're having issues with the EDC
interaction on the obelisk go to another
zone reload that zone go to orbit or
reload your character at some point it
will work I've heard people say like I
watched half a movie before I had got
logged in they're joking but I mean it's
some people are definitely taking some
time to get in there though
it may take you a little while
anything else you want to cover I'm
trying to think of stuff we haven't
covered yet and I feel like we've done a
decent job kind of hit it yeah we kind
of hit it I mean like I said we see any
objectives we got that we have a pretty
dance
we got seasonal pursue so basically
they're just changing in terms of the
iron banner stuff the the manner in
which things are obtained you know I'm
saying yeah a little bit a little more
through the quest the quest will be a
little different probably so they're
trying to give a little tweaks there do
you ever want Ironman or not to be
control
every son like they have like three a
season do they all need to be controlled
I am always of the mindset it can switch
but I remember in d1 when they did this
people would they would say oh oh why
can't he always be controlled daddy get
Mishra I loved it when we used to have
rifts once in a while we would have you
know saying like we would have different
things it's cool to mix it up it's okay
it's just a different flavor to it today
you appreciate control when it does come
back right you lie all yak shows you
this is a good play or whatever make you
blow kind of riff bro salute black rings
I ever see clash any of those could be
even once a season be like a this is a
rift like give it to him twice but I
don't care how much is the lane it
doesn't have to be the same mode every
every time and I would love to some play
would be cool if it was just like iron
banner hey this is your riff for the
season that be when the event actually
first yeah plus it promoted different
playstyles everybody kind of plays just
a and don't get my love all right better
control love it but you want variety
because now when we let's me my honest
when we see iron banner on the calendar
you do roll your eye a little bit
you like the reward but you like oh you
hear that okay you know zan it's gonna
be the same yeah yeah it's just kind of
one of those that I'd like to see them
mix it up I know they're always like
just easy we'll throw it in there cool
it's fine but there's just other modes
in there
why riff doesn't come back I don't know
maybe they're waiting for deeper game
some reason I think we are in the
problem is we are in the minority with
this thought process
I remember the D wasn't any shouting out
no podcast but I can call nobody out but
I've met many podcast like why are we
doing Claire just not fun right now
because I'm doing something different I
would hear it I'm just like bro you want
to do control every two weeks okay it's
just like oh let's we've been doing this
for a while I just would like every
softened mix it up on us and qui
depreciate it doesn't have to be all the
time you guys who love your control not
trying to shut down your party I'm just
saying sometimes good to mix it up
yeah shop for toys I liked it when
which between control and class even
have supremacy ever been uh uh okay well
in d1 maybe they rotated through a lot
of stuff then but I don't think they've
done it since T to the suburbs he didn't
even come back at first
mhm mhm and then when it did finally
come back I think it was
just now it's literally just in classic
mix I played classic mix with somebody I
was like oh yes the premise is in here
cuz it's not even on the damn director
is not even on a directory yeah I mean
sometimes little props in the rotator
for the 6v6 this clashes up there last
week
Janet is scorched by the way scorch
cannon craziness oh yeah I am so bad at
that mm-hmm I am okay at PvP but I am
really bad at score deep and I don't
know I I'm so terrible but I am NOT not
good mm-hmm scotch can't it but yeah
seems like supremacy has fallen out of
favor for some reason I liked it yeah it
was fun we played it knows like yeah
it'll make you you like sniping you
wouldn't be playing as much yeah you
would you would have to change
playstyles and I was like everything got
pushed so much to range with linear
fusions and stuff like that it's kind of
like right now why would it not be a bad
thing to move us around
our knowledge ideas that's just me
I think that's it some hell we can't get
to the end of these and I'm always kind
of surprised when we get here but I mean
it's you know holidays are coming
donning is going I actually haven't
fought the new sundial boss this week of
you I need to fight him no I was going
to find you I've been I've been obelisk
in my obelisk what I've been doing it's
been grinding all the bounties every
bounty and that's the biggest thing it's
like hey if you're gonna go play game
but pick up rebellious if you're gonna
go do strikes pick up your bounty see if
you're gonna go work on these things go
get your planetary boundaries like
bounty bounding bounding bounding
bounding bounding out all the time
bounties just all about yeah I will tell
you I finished up in it so it was the
screenshot I put out there and people
were like where's that from I finished
up an old like your one mission on PC
because it was like the dynasty mission
were you gonna go in IO to this like
weird little like underground Oh Mary it
was weird there's a cool picture out
there apparently a lot of people liked
it so I was cool with that but it was
just funny because it was just a couple
pictures I put out there and people were
liking him but I don't know if they
remembered where they were from good and
it's from like year 1 of destiny too and
I was like you guys have no idea how old
this is but it's cool you like it nice
but yeah I was trying to tidy some stuff
up I got sturm mmm oh you got started
because I hadn't touched it yet I had
like it's been too long and then when
you switched a PC after you get it on
ps4 I'm like do I really care about this
gun I really never did yeah I was like
there was not much of a point of me ever
getting it those like I'm not gonna get
it so I've been like every all like work
on stuff and then it's like I'm gonna go
knock out one thing off my quests then
then come back and lean so I've been
kind of clearing up some of those things
every softn - so I got Sturm finished up
dynasty nice but yeah mostly on the
mostly on the obelisk I'm cuz now I'm
level 32 and the season pass okay okay
I've got tangled short no Mars is up to
11
on that one max of crucibles full my
stats on that one we're showing like
every fourth match I was getting a drop
of fractal line I can't say that's for
sure cuz then I did like seven sports
dinner oh and I got zero fractal line
which actually really pissed me off
faster it's a good way to farm donning
but apparently not a good way for
fractal line and then as I'm about to
finish up another obelisk so every time
I go into sundial I can pull for weapons
so you get obelisk is one other obelisks
ones season passes one plus your og so
if you want to go for what and then when
you get to rank 92 in the season pass
every one of those drops is gonna have
two perks on the end so you like going
after a god roll into the season is
gonna be like legit it's gonna be yeah
you're gonna be getting no wait so many
rolls I want to clarify this when you
say two rolls at the end two visible
rolls and extra perk I'm just perfect
and a burden like the entry or say if
you have like outlaw rampage
you'd have outlawed rampage and
something under rampage and you can all
the two perks as to choice okay to
toggle choice like the way the ritual
weapons were like a way to put your
weapons last column okay and that's
usually the Murni everybody wants like
the good roll on know if you get that
like multi kill clip and rampage out
there's your options your set so mmm-hmm
okay I get you now I get you
yeah cuz that basically increases your
orangie if you know you get something
that you know you don't like but you got
it you get you get the good thing at the
bottom part you know I'm saying so you
get that flexibility okay and then one
of the Sun one of the obelisk you can
link multiple sundials so you can
literally go for like you don't have to
reset you'll have four weapons to pick
from they just be farm at the end it's
just gonna be granted out sundial just
going for those rolls because every 12
minutes for weapon rolls
so let me ask you this like every 15 but
yeah that's four rolls per one that's
gonna be a lot mmm tell me a lot so what
do you think cuz clearly I'll be this is
not spoilers I mean if you look at the
dawning I mean look at the Easy Bake
Oven there's a recipe per se forty yeah
you guys a so this is that spoilage a
lot you could see it so you know
actually it started the quest tells you
one of the quests the exotic quest for
that was it the ship or some thought
I'll be the the sparrow tells you that
you gonna have to deliver something to
say fourteen so being that we know he is
going to be an npc in the tower most
likely what the hell do you think he is
going to be doing or selling
well some people were saying there's
gonna be a fifth obelisk he's gonna be
managing that I don't know if it's gonna
be a way to interact with all the other
obelisks I don't know if he's gonna be
the permanent watch over time when he
sits there like hey we've linked him all
these obelisks they have to stay
permanent because we got to keep
Mercury's time like straight somehow
right well that's kind of a hunch is
that he's gonna be kind of the watch
over for that is he gonna stay
permanently I hope so he's a beast then
about us so I'm kind of hoping he stays
around I don't know what he's gonna is
he just gonna give us a couple exotic
quests and that's it I'm very curious I
don't know to be honest I was shocked
that he would be coming back to the
tower I did not expect that I didn't
think he was gonna be sticking out cuz
we said that last time I was like I
don't think he's staying around and this
time we're like standing you're gonna
have to like get him used to this time
or whatever it is basically like to get
used to this you know this era
you gotta come and get him into modern
era and I did not expect it and expect
him to stay and if he stays forever I
really don't know what he's gonna be
doing special I hope you got stuck way
out there in the hangar to see right now
is it like the flyby zone he's gonna get
like topol-m eyes all de la salud
everybody said they needed to give
people to go to the hey that's kinda
true I don't go to this is KDOT a reason
we go over today you gotta recently go
out there you got a hope for faction
rallies because half of them are out
there - mm-hmm yeah especially dead or
manolo but as well an arm what is you
know skittles foundation skittles Oh
[Laughter]
Adam Goodes
taste of rehabilitation could you get
your wife I don't know what he's talking
about he's talking about future or cold
but he's his killer
sorry I was very quiet because I was
trying not to laugh too hard in the
maintaining over here
the skittles foundation yes they are out
there to seek attractive monochrome she
got your hot topic is sitting next to
the skittles foundation yes GV and then
of course your red and gold out there
boys know when you said skittles that
made me remember I worked at Express
when I was a lot younger for like mm not
long
like for nine months I'm like that they
came out with a shirt it was just like a
button-down but I always joked it looked
like skittles rule up on that shirt tiny
lines cuz it's like like so many tight
lines but I swear everyone was a
different color it's just somebody like
pulling stripes of tiny little stripes
of every color all the way around this
whole damn shirt and I'm like what do
you do this is the ugly shirt I've ever
seen this is a shade I'm not a fan man
there yeah they've never really done it
for me and either Destiny's one or two
not a fan of either of those out of
Biffle shout out to their weapons though
I'm think because we're gonna be oh my
baby when we was stuck Oh big yeah
future well call yeah yeah there's a
little bit of me but like if I was using
that leg new monarchy weapon or that
feature will when I pulled it out I
couldn't shade it so at least I knew
where it came from now I know like okay
I know where like all my stuff I can
make it look how I want to previously
before it's like oh yeah this was future
war cult and it showed now it's just
like you get it from anywhere but yeah
it's it's not bad to cover up some of
those skittle foundation weapons oh good
no yeah when we come back guys it'll
probably be about the 9th that's when
the next Wahb is gonna be so the 10th
for us we've got iron banner which is
gonna happen while we're gone we've got
the legend sundial that will kick off
that week and we can talk about it we'll
have the Neville's run exotic Quest
Devil's ruined I'm sorry
and then we've got about a three week
gap yeah that's a big gap that's the big
one then you got the exotic quest
Bastian I heard that's a I've heard
boiler if you don't care don't listen
for like 15 seconds I've heard it's a
kinetic slug firing fusion rifle mmm all
I've heard I don't know if it's even
cold
Bullock rap or not anyway dunno spoiler
and then then in February so we get to
exotic quests we get no new bosses we
can no new obelisk this is what this is
where the honeymoons gonna be the test
cuz you get to the 28th on the 7th
through the 4th you get a whole month
basically because you get to exotic
quest when you're done with those quests
there is nothing new
two quests and you have a month of
nothing new
the van after said month of legend
difficulty they're probably gonna rotate
again through each boss on the 4th this
is when things get interesting
we got the Imperial foundation we don't
know what that is if you guys go look in
your emblems in your collections on
season right the one you told me about
the last one it says hey how much yeah
it will show how much polarised fractal
line you have donated to the empyrion or
something like that
mmm so this is gonna be potentially like
is this one of those community team
effort donate as much fractal line as
you can cuz you're still gonna be able
to learn the fractal line even though
y'all your table sits at once live when
you get to eleven eighty Prescott said
he showed you on Prescott yeah one of
you guys gets kosher mm-hmm toes like
it's the yeah the last emblem under
activities and you'll see it in-game and
it shows like how much Polaris fractal
and have you donated either to the
foundation or to Imperium or something
like that and you're like you can't do
it yet but you're like how am I gonna
know Nate this stuff well once you've
maxed out the obelisk cuz it's gonna go
somewhere so the stuff that we earn
throughout the rest of the season is
going to build this thing is this a
community event because it's for
everybody by the way this is free to all
players right so I don't know I'm
wondering what that's gonna be
and then the next week after that we
have crimson days and then we have three
weeks of nothing nobody know yeah I'm
being shoutout to you know shadow black
wings and vagabond are they like
definitely banners snuck in between
those creepy like they'll be down two
more game I know you a fan more banners
yeah sure
like after so luli bed is going down the
question is yeah how are they going to
survive during that period they have to
do something during that period else cuz
that that's a weird gap I mean so what
I'm hoping for is a secret I think my my
gut tells me there's still a secret
they can't go three weeks well okay if
we really think you've got from January
to March ninth almost two and a half
months nine weeks ten weeks whatever
that is mm-hmm you have the harder
difficulty which is not mesh maids and
not everybody's gonna do it you have
requests and you have one new boss for
PD and this foundation thing which we
don't know over the course of leg nine
to ten that's not that much that's not
that much there's no way they they are
being coy I could be shocked like I mean
this is also a holiday time so I mean
they're taking this break right now I
don't know if they're gonna come back
guns blazing or not but I am very
curious that's why I was like that's why
I'm reserving judgment on this season to
see how the next two months ago and
honestly if it's a lighter season that's
okay only bad dishes where next season
is gonna launch really close to
cyberpunk so we're all screwed yeah
that's good cop one question real quick
forever um when zero-hour happened
zero-hour was it it wasn't on the
calendar right oh hell no right
I've been girl we gonna get a secret we
gonna get a living in some kind of that
six-month cadence no I would see that as
being something anywhere in there then
you'd have a catalyst then you probably
have to grind over a few weeks right
yeah remember on Friday I want me to
make your strange cookie freezer yeah
yeah she'd give those out you'll be here
um but yeah it's like it's gonna be an
interesting into the season mostly just
because I don't know where it's going to
how the finding feeling is gonna wrap
because it feels solid right well it
started strong yes sundials are cool
obelisks are unique grind we've got
different weapons in the work on we got
a lot of stuff grind for when you're
kind of getting down to the end you're
like hey I got three of my four god
rules that I'm going for my obelisks are
done my peering foundation I'm good I've
got my legends done I've got one more
boss it's gonna I think it's gonna taper
it might taper pretty hard depending on
what's up their sleeve and that'll be
the keys
what ace up their sleeve or hopefully
it's not a two of clubs up their sleeve
like a shout out the black wings he said
I think he made me delete lately off the
flame man you mean the the sunbreakers
well that's what else hours people those
are the Titans he's cool with those that
are the ones he ran with that actually
helped with no armed war during the what
is it six French right though I mean
there's a possibility there's a
possibility but yeah it's too long a gap
he sums comment something's coming
there's definitely some type of secret
mission some type of quests some type of
quest lines something is happening and
I'm very curious to see how this season
ends two armed
transition into the next what the next
one will be called through like III kind
of like the story be in a way wait did I
said I just got a tightened up little
things smooth out certain transitions
but I like like you know what's gonna
happen with this thing now to say for a
t-tail like you know it they are
building it and it feels like it has
potential for the first time for destiny
to have consistent narrative that was
always there not going destiny right
like what's the story new story brewing
no it's a story this thing's going on
yeah I'm saying it and that's what I
like that each action effects it has an
opposite reaction type of thing I'm
liking it man so we'll see I'm I know we
got to see how this thing plays out but
it has started strong they still let you
do have it it's very I just want to
catch up in chat and I'm looking like a
war is if they're sleepy bonta's
confirms dual wield ace of spades next
season it is ready here first last we
ready in fact the bomb is like hey well
I'm out I'm out of town to vagabond oh
what are you talking about is gone he'll
give it I can't play to care to accounts
I can't even keep up with one I haven't
touched my hunter in a season Wow I
didn't touch him last season till the
very end that was the funny part I was
like hadn't touched him much I probably
played for like maybe some bounties cuz
I got him up to like 9:30 which was some
easy pickups like blues or honestly
probably turned in tokens to get him up
like 39 30s into the season I just
pulled all the season pass armored 950
before I logged out about 50 they didn't
even play him at all 50 so yeah don't
break the bank you are there that times
not that big of a deal snow
man that is about all I got I think
we've kind of we can speculate as to
what the end of the calendar is gonna
have on it but we really really really
don't know until we see it but secret
there's a lot of time we got to wait and
see what comes in said hi but a man
that's all I got so guys I think we'll
be we will be off for a couple of weeks
I've got a holiday travel if we're both
in town and there's something cool that
happens we'll try and talk about it but
stay tuned on the Twitter follow us you
guys know where to find us
so if something does come up otherwise
expect our next one on January 10th
should be around the time after the next
blob we'll see what legend is like we'll
kind of get a feel for you know
everything coming through so that's all
I got a winner about ILP what do you got
are you guys on break are you guys
taking a hiatus
what do you guys up to this will be the
last ILP this Sunday of 2019 so we're
closing I'm just gonna do a little fun
like have some low change episodes it
normal this gaming topics kind of like
good year and the year edition kind of
things fun like have you so come check
us out man you know you know iron Lords
podcast on YouTube the IOP YouTube
channel so that will be Sunday and also
will be our last Sunday at 11 a.m. I
know King at happy about that they were
like yes it goes back to 1:00 p.m. in
the new year so we'll do that man so
yeah check us out there and also again
please support the good brothers that
Lords of gaming net tremendous articles
they have been killing it they've been
pumping out content all these guys I'll
to my boy I Bob done he's got I'm gonna
try to get him or last word he's this
guy's very knowledgeable and um he's got
a good good uh actually he said we had a
article said bungee you made sort of
over like fun again and I was like okay
all right so salute him he's got that we
got some boys our destiny content going
up and of course my brother King David
with king of the statues he's got a real
sick one that's coming up I should be
hopefully later today you guys got a
check it's a vintage but at 19 these
babies and all you go you guys gonna
love this kind of stuff that he's got
cooking but um yeah we appreciate
support management we'll be seeing some
girls and yeah this will be the final
ILP of 2019 Sunday 11 a.m.
check us out and of course be Lord
Cardinal on Twitter and the last word
podcast on Fridays we take a little
hiatus
you know holidays Christmas and New
Year's and just winding down and
chilling but all yeah we will definitely
resurface check the twitter when the
time is right and the Warlock laughs
that's right my man tramatic salut
I love you ready girl I got its guess
would will what but oh yeah man salute
guys you got you guys are tremendous so
you guys give us anything you love the
banter the bickering the funniness
always pleasure doing a podcast with
this gentleman here so uh that's all I
got man what about you man uh yeah I
mean me too on all this I'll be
traveling a little bit over Christmas I
actually will be coming back Thursday so
sir still might pop up on Friday um but
yeah I mean I'll be like take a break
and work in in the holidays and travel
the new years and all that crazy stuff
so it'll be lighter but I'm gonna try
and get a couple basic videos done just
some help for some new players just the
schedule and spread out while I am
traveling a gun podcast will be up for
you I will try and get it up today my
channel will be up tomorrow audio I will
try and get up today I'm gonna spend a
little more time on the audio guys so it
won't be as quick trying to get a little
more effects on there just kind of
normalized voices and learn a little bit
of that and then I'll try and get my
video up tomorrow while I'm traveling
but yes sir we'll be coming here in
about 45 minutes so and that will start
the Friday but I just want to say thank
you to all you guys if you were
listening to us on audio thank you for
all the support there that one just
slowly trickles up higher and higher
spread the word if anybody you know in
the Destiny world enjoys this the videos
I continue to grow on views and just
thank you all for the support we're
always trying to climb and get bigger
and spread we couldn't do this without
you guys and it's been 2 years that
we've been doing this thing it's not
quite a hundred and four specific
episodes cuz we have our weekends off
and stuff like that sometimes it doesn't
come together but two years of podcast
man it's been a blast so thank you sir
for being an awesome co-host as well
thank you all who are in chat leave
comments on the channels and everything
you guys have been great it's been an
awesome couple years we are wrapping up
the decade in pretty positive fashion
from where we started this a few years
ago so absolutely we went from Mercury
and down
Kito maker restore the decade circle so
we're gonna start a new when we get down
there if you guys are just jumping in we
are wrapping up but I'm gonna send you
guys over to say hello to somebody else
who's planed and they'll they're
grinding out some stuff right now so for
episode 85 December 20th thank you guys
for everything past years has been
awesome
lots more to come next year Dusty's in
an awesome spot and keeps going so have
yourselves a good one we will see you
soon and for this episode it has been
the last word